hey there valuetainers you're watching
the valuetainments and you're getting
[ __ ]
is that going to go on the blooper reel
now yeah i [ __ ] that one up
all right valuetainers are watching two
valuetaining questions or evaluating
you you got this one then i [ __ ] up
twice so hey there valuetainers this is
vitamin questions refreshing fit and
watching two podcasters talk about
dating topics that's not it at all i
don't know it's valuetainers man
valuetainers goddammit
hey there valuetainers you're watching
value to any questions with two
podcasters fresh at fit let's get into
it baby let's go
what made you start a podcast about
dating oh man experience
uh reading books and then just having
like the camaraderie of the brotherhood
man yeah i mean honestly a lot of guys
struggle with it man and for us we kind
of figured out because we weren't always
go with girls we kind of like figured
this stuff out you know throughout our
teens and adult years and we're kind of
able to come back and share like hey
guys we figured it out this is what we
did emulate what we did hopefully we'll
become successful as well because a lot
of it regardless if you get girls or not
you're going to become successful
because you're going to work on yourself
you're going to get in the gym you're
going to make more money you're going to
work on your business you're going to
you know
become a better man in general so
regardless you're going to win and the
byproduct of that is the women and as a
guy your biggest problem for most part
is dating girls because guess what if
you know how to get girls it's going to
be a big part of your life so
understanding that helps you a long way
so and understanding female in nature
too so you don't get finesse because if
you don't know what you're doing bro you
end up cruising for a bruising what is
your message in a nutshell become the
best version of yourself guys so that
women are byproduct of your success
versus chasing the women man you know
chase excellence and the woman will
follow it if you chase the women you're
going to lose a lot of excellence in the
process understand yes getting girls is
a part of life but the main core is
having the mindset having the body uh in
a good shape and also as well having
your money a point because guess what be
who you are but become the best version
of yourself to get what you want in life
fitness
finances
female nature
understand frame you're going to be good
there you go why are people so
interested in the topics you discuss
dating is stuff for a lot of guys man a
lot of guys are struggling out there you
know obviously instagram online dating
in general has become very difficult for
the average guy you know most got most
most guys are invisible to most women so
a lot of guys struggle with this and you
know we're kind of letting them know hey
listen man we get it we were where you
guys were we understand that it's a very
competitive marketplace nowadays days
girls want the best of the best and you
have to become nowadays if you you have
to become if you want to come if you
know what i'm saying yeah long story
short instagram has changed the whole
game lisa is one of the biggest date
apps in the world instagram by the way
however returning regarding our girls
and dating look at the same time yes
it's controversial how we say things but
it's a fact it's the truth so either you
like it or you don't it's what it is
improve or die adapt or die what's next
for fresh and fit well you know i've
been trying to get into the drug game
recently is the camera still on [ __ ]
right
now i mean just we're going to keep uh
you know doing our show the goal is to
hit 1 million subs right we're trying to
hit it by the end of this year we just
we started our podcast officially
october 26 i think was our first episode
in studio of 2020 we're about 18 months
in now at this point so yeah man trying
to hit 1 million and then from there i
think you know expand and keep growing
on a world tour probably yes go to
different states like australia go to
the uk countries different countries
yeah
we got fans from all over the world
supporters shout out to y'all yeah and
uh just add more value you know and uh
yeah
what's the sexiest accent ooh
british
would you like some tea and crumpets
yeah dogs are cats
dogs bro i got a dog hero
awesome shout out to him she be new
those coins worst date you've ever been
on worst date
the feminists yeah i've been on daily
feminists before it's amazing though
like you out with them and you just tell
them yeah you're
that feminism is stupid i'm like oh okay
you know what i'm saying like if you
just don't care like it's just amazing
yeah they'll change they'll change and
bend and fold you know i'm saying girl
girls want to be able to follow a guy
man trust me guys they have this oh
feminism equal to you nothing bro they
want to make a sandwich for you hey dude
trust me make me say talk cat man they
want to make a sandwich and follow your
lead i'm telling y'all bro what
celebrity is crushing the hypergamy game
leonardo
yeah all the way he's he's he's out here
he ain't even dane chicks that's over 25
man
if i ever meet you bro i'm gonna die you
up like yo [ __ ] you're a real one dog
future future and leonardo dicaprio bro
future selling these girls dreams
between myron and walter who gets more
girls
fresh definitely smash way more tricks
than me yeah okay you know what i'm not
gonna stop i'm gonna silent killer you
don't see me coming plus i'm black as
hell so at night time you can't see me
but i'll be there with you scott was
going on when i first met him he was
going like three days a day bro i was
like bro you got to chill with this man
what the hell i'm going to do the
business i show a love and appreciation
going out three days a day bro like what
the [ __ ] like no so he wrote it back but
yeah this guy definitely what have you
read more of the quran or the rational
mail
how's it going
oh god
right
uh recently the rational male but yeah
the quran obviously when i was younger i
went to sunday school and [ __ ] but uh
proverbs is a very good book celebrity
crush i kind of really hit them already
i mean uh i met them already
i can't think of one bro right now this
porn star is bro oh for me no
i mean you could consider that a celeb
okay
social media ruined relationships 100
bro it didn't kill it but it definitely
stabbed it in the heart let's just blend
in right now
[ __ ] bro you got a girl bro she's on
instagram send a dm kind of miami it's
corrupt yeah it's give it's giving women
a crazy advantage uh in the dating
marketplace which you know a lot of guys
aren't able to kind of compete compete
with you know because most guys are
terrible at taking pictures having a
good instagram profile whatever whereas
like a chicken have a mediocre profile
and still get like a [ __ ] to hit them up
whereas like as a guy you gotta have a
top-tier profile and on top of that
still get curved when you send girls
messages so yeah social media has
definitely heard it and ben it's
benefited women more than benefited for
sure what's more important looks or
character looks come first and then she
won't give a [ __ ] about your character
until she's attracted to you first
anyway yeah so you got to get through
the door first what about a woman looks
your character oh for us uh yeah it
looks bro because for short term looks
for long term character but let's go
first no matter what yeah i mean here's
the thing as long as she's like you know
coachable and everything like that you
can you can contort her and conform her
to fit your program like men lead women
follow so like you want a girl that's
gonna be coachable that you can turn
into the best version of herself as your
girl anyway so you know obviously you
want a good foundation there but looks
come first and then the character you
can you can build her up you want to
train girls are they dogs i guess
apparently allegedly
we're a massager so i don't know
i got to continue on with the trend
right any thoughts on h3h3
oh our buddies over there yeah yeah
they're they're why are you scared bro
yeah we challenged them we told them yo
y'all want to debate we can do it bro
are you running now bro like we're here
running now
yeah he's scared man you're running now
we'll happily debate you guys and we're
not going to do ad hominem attacks we'll
actually attack your argument
surprisingly we're not going to make fun
of the way you look and everything else
like you guys oh you guys are in cells
don't attack the argument you're good
cells okay best relationship advice
you've ever received oh man leave him
and follow that's really like you know
like you you got to put yourself as a
priority and then girls will align to
you
it's just your turn things are for a
season for a reason don't make it be
forever because no nothing's forever but
at the same time it's just just your
turn basically so valuetainers that was
valuetaining questions with two
podcasters fresh to fit okay i got it
right this time no need for another take
check us out on youtube fresh and fit on
there instagram fresh fit podcast unplug
fit freshman ceo for our personal
accounts check us out on patreon.com and
yeah guys check us out we're live every
day monday through friday pretty much
money mondays womanizer wednesdays
call in show fridays 6 p.m and then
nighttime show we start typically 8 9 pm
with the love ladies you guys want to
see me debate and lose hair follicles
check us out freshly found youtube
peace bbc gang
[Music]
you